bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono fa vj ed oggi siamo
in un nuovo video con tempi adesso fa
chi era perché inizio così iniziò così
perché nell'ultimo video ragazzi non ho
fatto la intro e siccome non ho fatto la
intro il 90 per cento di commenti e
stato va bene va bene adesso la parola
spetti devo spiegare sta cosa mi hanno
sorpreso tantissimo ragazzi commenti
dell'ultimo video che ho fatto quindi
quello di questa mattina dove vi faccio
vedere un attimo una cosa allora il
video parte critica
natura mierda e ci sono io che per circa
un minuto e mezzo di video dico
dittatura mierda così a caso perché in
poche parole nel gioco si spara gente a
caso non ha un senso cioè in realtà cela
però vabbè lasciamo perdere il resto del
video è un po più parlato però diciamo
che il primo minuto e mezzo sparato a
caso presenza di un motivo la parola
dittatura merda i commenti del video
sono geniali ma geniali devole no vabbè
alcuni veli leggo fan troppo dire
famiglia erano ha capito un cazzo del
video alla fine che cosa che se c'è da
capire in umido delle spy a caso la
gente volevi che ti dicessi tipo a si
sta sparando ok è morto è grande e freud
sparo forte che cazzo cambia alla fine
tanto lussi della stessa qualcosa dove i
capi c'è da capire un gioco dove spari
alla gente che basta hanno anche sputato
sulla web cam in realtà percentuale
questa 25 per cento dei commenti con non
ho capito un cazzo di quello che è
successo altro 25 per cento dei commenti
con non hai fatto la intro restante 50
per cento dei commenti con dittatura
mierda che va bè ciechi e la presa sul
ridere che era quello l'intento è non
mangia niente di strano invece c'è un
sacco di gente questa qua è un questo è
un argomento un po più generale perché
non è solo in questo video è già
capitato del gioco ma perché non hai
detto bella ragazzi all'inizio che non
ha fatto è bello ragazzi e a parte che
stefano matta chissà cosa del fare così
grazie stai proprio le volevo parlare
gli sta roba ragazzi perché da un po che
va avanti sta situazione nel senso che
c'è un sacco di gente che quando non
faccio la intro mi scrive sotto si
parola introna l'hai fatta non è un bel
video ma ce la fai a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuto che sono video sono fa vj
resto del video può essere anche una
completa merda bei ragazzi se video è
piaciuta sono momento mi piace ci
vediamo non possono video bella ragazzi
così in realtà però un bel video basta
che dico la intro poi di cazzo te ne
frega io in realtà allora nei miei video
sono molto cazzaro questa cosa qua
pensavo si fosse capita negli ultimi
quattro anni che io faccio video che
cazzari pare tanto anche quindi a volte
se io entro che sono tipo in mutande che
sto ballando sul lampadario e non dico
la intro in quel momento
è una roba un po basilare nel senso
dovreste andare più avanti della entrò
nel senso che se ogni tanto non vedete
la intro non è che sarà il taglio le
vene ma che cazzo ne frega se non c'e la
intro allora facciamo così farò un video
di 10 minuti in loop dove dico bella a
tutti i ragazzi e ogni qualvolta
caricherò un video su youtube nel quale
non c'era intrometto in descrizione
ragazzi per chi sente il bisogno di
sentire la intro perché se non un
orgasmo non le orecchie click il link
qua sotto che ci sono dieci minuti dove
io dico solo bella tutti i ragazzi per
10 minuti così almeno qualsiasi video
diventa bello ma ti seguono anche i
ragazzini non puoi mettere questi video
e poi in realtà il primo che mi scrive
sotto i commenti fari perché non porti
gta comunque è allora ragazzi quello che
volevo dirvi io e che in generale il mio
canale da un bel pò di tempo e con un
bel po di tempo intendo tre o quattro
anni non è più lineare della serie non è
più bello di ragazzi mente questo nuovo
video ogni singolo video ovunque non è
gameplay 7 giorni su 7 in realtà ci sono
un sacco di video che vanno fuori dalla
norma perché mi piace pasticciare tra
virgolette con il mio form comunque in
realtà io lo capisco perché bella tutti
i ragazzi un po il mio marchio nel senso
che la gente per strada mi che questa è
una cosa fantastica del mo.vi racconto
da gente ogni tanto quando mi riconosce
per strada capita che mi dica dai favi
urla mi un bella tutti ragazzi magari
cesta l'anziana lì vicino che è che già
vede un chi è questo belgiovine sarà uno
della televisione e poi puntualmente
dopo che ti sei fatto la foto quel
cristiano dice mi fai un bel a tutti i
ragazzi e tu che cazzo devi di voi è
fantastico è sta roba qua l'ho visto
anche in un video di youtube che l'ha
detto e cazzo quanto è vero vi faccio
l'esempio siamo in treno c'è un
cristiano che mi riconosce mi vede da
lontano la faccia è sempre la stessa
pian piano si avvicina a me mi fa ciao
favi ci facciamo una foto e la mia
reaction ovviamente è certo va bene
facciamoci un self il ragazzo fa il self
tutto contento grazie fa 26 was in
grande e io grazie grazie mille eccetera
che poi io sono anche tv dove son state
torna al suo posto e tutta la gente che
sta nel vagone del treno inizia a
guardarmi perché non sa chi cazzo sono
cercando anche di non farsi vedere
bellissimo come se non me ne accorgessi
questa roba ripeto lo aveva detto anche
youtube in un ultimo video che ha fatto
e mickey è quanto vero altra cosa
fantastica che succede quando siamo in
giro che la gente mi riconosce e magari
sono anche con degli amici non lo so
ed è bellissimo che magari della gente
inizia a seguirci e pensando che io non
senta fanno tra di loro
ricevo e io in tutto questo sono lì come
un minchione della serie non essere
timido non essere timida non essere
timido e poi arriva amiche nella foto e
poi la gente mi fissava beh così da una
vita
non so neanche come cazzo siamo finiti a
parlare di questo discorso che siamo
partiti da dittatura merda e siamo
arrivati a come mi riconosce la gente
per strada vabbè a prescindere da tutto
il discorso generale di questo video
dove siamo andati a sforare nella più
completa idiozia era semi seguite come
youtube e ragazzi sappiate che io sono
instabile della serie che ogni tanto me
ne posso uscire tipo non c'è dovuto
fatto uscire maroni pieni durante
quest'anno che tipo una cover musicale
alla cazzo di cane anche se io non
faccio cover ma ho sempre fatto gameplay
perché mi va di variare oppure tipo
quello che ho fatto con la con l'acqua
all'esperimento oppure il colloquio di
lavoro cioè io ogni tanto faccio cose
divertenti perché mi va di farle cioè
non segue uno schema non prendo youtube
c'è per me you tube è una roba che deve
essere divertente cioè mi devo divertire
a farla quindi se a me va ad iniziare un
video dicendo dittatura mierda e lo dico
per due minuti attacca e book azioni
ragazzi spero che sia tutto più chiaro
con questa cosa anche se va bene non era
più che altro perché ciò voglia di fare
una discussione così e basta e sono devo
rifare letto però non lo faccio perché
sono un ribelle dittatura mierda spero
che questo video vi sia piaciuto facendo
l'auto quindi questo è un bel video però
che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi come se 2000
vissuto un momento è un mi piace anche a
pagina di facebook come nido totale del
tiziano saresti di sky tv ci vediamo il
prossimo video belle ragazze